finally a cloud of blood came out of his
pee hole I had just gone my first set of
acrylic nails put on I ended up by
giving my friend a tiger snippets penis
with scratches I was a little sheltered
so I took the 10 [ __ ] literally like
that's what do you do to the Betty's you
blow like it's a balloon
he wasn't amused I was on my period but
my boyfriend and I decided to have sex
anyway everything was great until we
both start to feel pain he pulled his
dick in the condom was gone he started
digging around on my bloody vagina for
it while complaining about his tip
hurting his penis was covered in blood
he thought something was stuck in his
pee hole so I went to the bathroom and
tried to pee it out for 30 minutes
finally a cloud of blood came out of his
pee hole wow I was really horny so I
drove to my ex's house to have sex the
next morning I realized I never took my
check out much his penis was so big that
he pushed it so far up he fished around
for 15 minutes it finally got it out I
was giving my horrible ex a [ __ ] and
he ejaculated so forcefully that the [ __ ]
came out of my nose I didn't expect to
say penis today I got my daily penis and
gross
[Music]